obviously
i have fallen in love with your farm
animals like everybody on social media
and i think that that
genuine passion is something that comes
through in rams big time
but that was not something that i was
aware of when i first fell in love with
jurassic park so it was making me wonder
now
was that something that you were
channeling while playing alan grant back
then
no i've always been attached to animals
i grew up in a in a sort of animal
loving house
and my parents were more obviously
fond of their animals than they were of
their children
and well more more yeah no they loved it
they loved us but they but they but the
the the dogs and the cats got all the
cuddles you know what i mean
uh i have that same problem in this
house
and with rams it was it wasn't um
a difficult jump because i i have my own
sheep here at any
time i have about 30 sheep uh i
might my sheep are a little bit prettier
than the ones in ram so i have
suffolk sheep they're black faces and
black black socks
they're gorgeous uh and um
yeah i i think i have an affinity for
animals which is
and it's been nice being here during um
what is obviously a quiet time
during um during a pandemic uh
because um uh or none of my animals are
aware of
what's going on anywhere and um they're
all
very pleased to see me that's gratifying
such animals as they are in in in
jurassic
tend to be vaguely on the hostile side
and um and you wouldn't want to run into
them on a dark night
apart from the herb eating ones
which probably squashed you of course
squash you but by the time they get
around to passing it which take about
half a day they're so big
no i don't think there's anything of an
animal lover in uh in
anna grant he's he's um he likes bones
you know the living things are not not
not such
not so attractive that's fair that's
fair
so jumping into rams full force now
when you first signed on for the project
even with all the experience you've had
over the years
is there any particular new challenge
that rams pose that you're especially
excited to tackle
um i look if every film is a challenge
and that was very challenging for me
because i just finished blackbird with
roger michelle and
susan sarandon and so on and um
that had been the third film on throttle
that i that i'd and this was number four
back to back and four and one years
is probably more than as the doctor
would advise
and i was reluctant to take this on i
was reluctant to take it on because it
is a
it it it's sort of a remake
of an icelandic film and i i wasn't
interested in doing a remake and then i
realized when i read the script it was
entirely
en entirely different really in tone
and and and in substance
and um uh
and and it was exhausting to do because
i'm just sort of in every scene
and i never got a break and it took me
right through to christmas and then i
i sort of got home a sort of limp sack
of a man
that i i i'm glad i did it because i've
had such
really good feedback from the film and
people
um you know i've been looking at sort of
what's around in current cinema
and what's up for you know oscars and so
on
and some really good films to be had but
they're mostly bloody miserable you know
and and and and depressing and
and i i don't i sort of don't want to
i'm reluctant to watch them because i
and you know life's life's pretty bleak
as it is
uh i'm so concerned for
humanity and my friends and my
my loved ones and and for the countries
that i
i love best so um the idea of watching
more mystery is unappealing but
um you know people come out of this film
going oh god i just feel better about
things
so um yeah i just coined the phrase in
the last
interview i did it's not a it's not a
feel-good film but it's a feel better
film
does that make sense it does make sense
very much
and i feel like i need more of those in
my life and i think i'm just connecting
the dots here because these are both
australian films but if you want another
one in that category you should go check
out penguin bloom
it's so good oh yeah it's phenomenal and
it's it's got heartbreaking components
as well
but it also leaves you in a place where
you're inspired and hopeful
i must remember that i've got a
yeah um
my friend rachel house she in it she
is in it she's quite good in it too
yeah um and she's also in this
animated film so soul
yes that's the other one i've got to see
both those she
she's great in both of them yeah she's
um she's i i love her dearly
and um i'll see anything that she's in
uh in the hunt for the wilder people she
was the
acting coach for julian and
we did the table read and there was
there was no one to play the
social worker at this point and so she
read it
and at the end of the table it's like i
said oh
yeah you might as well play it yeah come
on yeah you play it
so last minute thing
i mean taika uses her in absolutely
everything he does and why wouldn't you
she's
she's i have a
i have a rachel house inspired question
for you because i was
i just had a lengthy interview and we
talked a good deal about something that
i've become a little obsessed with she
kept telling me about the value of
culture
on new zealand film sets so
given the fact that i think what she was
describing
would benefit sets all over the world
what is something about filming a movie
in new zealand that you would like to
take with you
to other sets that are taking place in
other parts of the world
well the first thing is we we always
start with a with
a blessing and
um there's always someone who speaks of
and to the land
to to to the air the mountain
um at the sea you know and
um uh the mountain the land the sea
and um um
i always feel like um
that sort of um that opens a door
to something else and and also
also gives you permission in a weird way
and
and brings brings you together uh
as a cast and crew in in a sort of
spiritual sense
i think that's very important
um but i i do the older i get the more i
believe in ceremony of
of some kind i
i'm not in any way religious
but i love going into cathedrals for
instance if i'm if i'm in europe
okay and there's nothing to do on a
sunday
uh this often very little to do on a
sunday
in europe so go to a cathedral go to
even song
listen to the choir and just
and just um uh
partake in that in that ceremony
and and
there's something about old rituals
that's very kind of
comforting and um
and puts you into a context
i mean you can walk through a cathedral
as a tourist and go well that's
beautiful
oh look at those lovely arches but to
actually
contextualize it and then and and pat
and be part of a ceremony that's been
conducted
in that building since the day
it was you know they finished building
it
i think it's very very i mean just to
know what she
would would take in terms of that
i hope i pronounced this correctly but
she was explaining something to me
called manaki manakitana
just this this idea of
essentially opening your arms to
everyone on set and creating an
environment where everybody feels
supported
and i i just really appreciated that and
i wish like not
not only on film sets but every place of
business that that
quality more seriously
oh that's very that's very um that's
that's beautiful
isn't it yeah i'm gonna ask you another
rams question because one of the things
about the movie that really struck me
is that it gives you a little bit of
everything it gives you
comedic beats and then it gets into some
deep tragedy so for you tackling that
role
how do you make sure that you are
hitting all of those different styles
and tones
but still making the character feel
cohesive well
um yeah that's a good question i hope
i've done so do you think i did sir i
100 think you did and i'm not right
i'm speaking to you i truly i truly do
think you nailed this role and i'm going
to highly recommend
it to our viewers thanks so much
um well look i i think
um uh i've always thought
it's it it's it's a mistake
to try and be comedic just stay true
to straight stay true to the character
um i i um
especially as i'm not a comedian
one of the things uh that's very uh
that's very annoying is how
and and and and many of them are uh
many of my friends are how good
comedians can be
as as actors it doesn't work the other
way around
don't ask answer to be funny it's just
that's the worst mistake
but you can ask a comedian to act and
and it's usually
you'll usually get something just
fantastic when you if you think of
billy connolly uh
um you know eric banner was a stand-up
comedian
what the hell now he's now he's one of
the best leading men in the world what
that's really annoying he's really
annoying
if he wasn't such a nice guy i'd be
furious
and oh um
rain wilson comedian
his performance is is for me is the best
thing
in blackbird did you see blackbird i
didn't see it
but i was just watching the trailer very
recently and i have it on my list
well he plays a very very funny
character
with such sort of sad and poignant
dimensions
and just lifts the film out of um
into another dimension and i love him
and
i i just think he's fantastic i mean
steve martin what a great actor
robin williams could be just
fabulous he was like into a film with
robin
and um uh
but also um
i wouldn't want to be a comedian because
they're sometimes the they're the
saddest people there was something just
heartbreaking about
robin just to be in his company that
would break my heart because i i just
felt
you know it did didn't you
you know you didn't need to be massively
empathetic to just
feel such a deep sadness inside him i
i it's hard to explain but
he only felt right when he had an
audience
and when he didn't have an audience when
it was just you he was so desolate
and then he'd come out of his trailer
and there'd be four or five
you know pas and runners and and
and assistant directors and stuff like
that we have an audience would you just
be
be robin he'd be riffing off people's
names and
just most extraordinary mind i've ever
come across
ask me another question lunch isn't
ready yet all right i could definitely
keep going and going here i'll squeeze
in
my jurassic park three questions so i
get it in
because oh good no surprise here
i truly do have a great appreciation for
every single installment of that
franchise but there's one thing that
stands out that people love to share on
social media as a meme now
and i'm wondering your take on it the
very first time you read the scene in
jurassic park 3 when alan has the dream
and wakes up and
the raptor says his name what was your
first impression when you read that
oh that's pretty cool yeah that's it
yeah i i was just talking to someone
earlier in the day
who who said i do i
really like jurassic park three and it
gets it gets
um it gets an unfair tr i think
he was from rotten tomatoes
i think it was him and i said thank you
very much
um i agree that the last the last 10
minutes of
way too easy and and way too hard but i
think
up to that point it's pretty damn good
but more than that for me i'd
by the time i got to number three
probably a bit late in the day
i'd sort of worked out how to play that
character
and um which i hadn't really
quite gotten around to in in in in
in the first one and we're still trying
to work out
uh what how how do you play that guy
uh in the hat something that comes
completely naturally to someone like
harrison ford naturally to me
and something that um chris pratt
fantastic guy
has given a lot of thought to and really
worked out how to do it
and you have to think out how to do that
it's a special skill
it's not um
you're not just playing a character you
you need to apply
a whole bunch of you you need a whole
skill set you need a whole armory to
play an action hero
and um and i wish i'd known
what those skills were when we
when we did the first one but there we
are
you're so self-deprecating and all i all
i see
is is confidence in basically everything
that you're describing right
now in alan grant in the first movie
well that's good i got away with it then
you most certainly did here here's a
weird thor
ragnarok question for you because this
has been a very hot topic of
conversation among the collider staff
and it's a it's a little offbeat i'm
warning you
okay so are you matt damon and luke
and luke hemsworth are you playing as
guardian actors
or did loki kidnap the real sam neil and
he's forced
i can't take credit for that it's
something swirling around social media
but we've been having fun with the idea
that's hilarious
but look i mean when when i went to see
the film
because i'm not really entirely you know
nerdously you know rusted on to the
marvel
to the marvel franchise i was completely
baffled by so many things okay
and i went with friends who sort of knew
a bit more than me
do you do you know what planet we're on
at the moment and
is is is that is that hopkins or or
is it hi was that like i
and they were explaining it they said
you're in the film why do we have to
explain it to you i think
i just i'm i'm a bit lost i'm
truly lost here but um
no i shouldn't really confess to that i
should really know what's going on but
it's it is it it is a strange
it is it's it's not actually
it's that it looks like tony hopkins but
it's not
even as someone who is steeped in that
franchise all the time
i still have many a questions that i
don't have the answers to right now
they're making me leave so i want to
record
a proper outro because i meant what i
said before
to everybody out there who has not seen
rams
you can get it itunes amazon anywhere
you could purchase a movie digitally on
february 5th
and i i genuinely recommend it it is
everything that sam described in those
original
uh goals for the movie and it is a
delight
you should check it out sam thank you so
much for for hanging out with us
it's a great pleasure thank you very
much for the chat